3 milliards de dollars pour aider
l'ukraine à franchir le cap de ses six
mois de conflit six mois pendant
lesquels l'armée ukrainienne contre
toute attente est parvenu à tenir tête à
l'une des armées les plus redoutés de la
planète au pentagone à la fin du mois de
février dernier aucun officier général
aucun tacticien ne pouvait prédire
l'efficacité de la résistance
ukrainienne bien sûr joe biden s'était
engagé à soutenir volodymyr zelensky
mais dans les premiers jours de
l'invasion le président américain lui a
surtout proposé de l'exfiltrer on s'en
souvient la réponse du président
ukrainien avait été cinglante je cite je
n'ai pas besoin d'un taxi mais de
cartouches pour me battre la phrase
avait fait mouche ici aux etats-unis sur
le président bien sûr mais également sur
le congrès qui depuis lors a
systématiquement et de manière
transparente izal non seulement autorisé
mais encouragé l'aide militaire
américaine à l'ukraine ici dans la
capitale américaine pas un bâtiment
officiel sans son drapeau ukrainien mais
surtout au département d'état et bien
entendu au pentagone les diplomates
ukrainiens en poste à washington ont
littéralement table ouverte il faut des
armes pour l'ukraine des armes modernes
et en grande quantité alors à
intervalles réguliers et dans le secret
des ports de l' us navy les navires
chargés d'obus de 155 des pièces
d'artillerie moderne et des systèmes
d'armes à courte et moyenne portée
appareils pour des destinations secrète
avant de réapparaître sur la ligne de
contact la ligne de front de l'est
ukrainien une guerre par délégation donc
assumé par joe biden qui pourtant réfute
totalement la belligérance sans le
soutien américain pourtant l'ukraine
seraient aujourd'hui certainement
intégralement aux mains des russes ici
chacun s'accorde à le dire alors tant
qu'il y aura des soldats ukrainien pour
se battre l'amérique leur promets qu'ils
n'auront pas besoin de taxi et ne
manqueront pas de cartouches